from bloomberg quick take i'm madison
mills we recently saw supreme court
nominee amy conibera introduce her
adopted children to the national stage
who are black
this mirrors a national conversation
about race and blended families
joining us today to discuss transracial
adoption is april dinwoody april thank
you so much for joining us
april is the host of the podcast born in
june raised in april and she is here to
unpack
all of this with us april how how are
you doing how are you holding up
i'm doing fine i'm doing well this uh
this conversation is one that i'm
grateful for
at a time like this we are very grateful
that you're joining us i want to start
um with a question about
amy coney barrett who we mentioned at
the top um can you break down
some of the highlights and challenges
that her and her family might face
with the racial makeup of that family
well you know on a on a a regular day
in a regular family when you integrate
a different race of your child into your
family if you're a white family
especially in a white community
you are very much exposed and you're
very visible as a family and those
children
who are black and brown and white
communities and white families are very
visible when you put them on a
world stage that just amplifies that
reality of
their family and especially for minor
children i feel like it's really
challenging uh to protect their
emotional psychological and physical
safety
when it's so so broad and everybody has
something to say about it
now that there are also other big
deep challenges that are about um their
their culture
their race and um making sure that it's
honored within their family whether
you're
a supreme court nominee or not
and we've already seen some folks come
out on twitter saying things like well
amy coney barrett can't be racist
because she has chosen to adopt black
children can you respond to that and
tell me your thoughts on that whole idea
well that's just simply not true right
um
you know white parents who adopted black
and brown children
have a much more um
urgent incentive to understand race
dynamics and to be
anti-racist but that's just not the case
that they
they actually embody that um there is
there is a real lack of you know
preparation and training and
conversation about
what differences of race with children
coming into families especially black
children to white families
there's a real lack of conversation
about that and preparation for families
so we just can't simply place uh an
anti-racist
you know sort of spirit on a family
simply because
they adopt a black or brown child i know
that people want to do that
um it also doesn't mean that those
parents are racist either
uh at this so we just can't place that
on that and there's so much more work to
do
to actually understand that idea and
quite frankly the people that you ask
that you need to ask the most
are grown trans-racially adopted persons
who have now been raised in white
families
to understand the dynamics uh within
those families and what that meant to
them
me growing up and you've lived
this experience this is personal for you
so i'm wondering if you can just tell us
a little bit about your experience with
transracial adoption and and
some of the challenges you faced sure uh
i was placed in foster care temporary
foster care at
uh as a newborn basically and was in
foster care for
several months before i was placed in um
an adoptive home pre-adopted home
and was adopted thereafter and that
family is white
and they're new england white whatever
that means right like they're very very
white
and i grew up in a very white new
england town
and i'm a light-skinned woman obviously
a black biracial woman
uh but i stood out and uh there were
definitely things that
um were challenges in terms of just
like not seeing color which is something
that i think you know a lot of
white well-meaning well-intentioned
folks including my parents um
liked to say uh but that didn't provide
that psychological emotional
and even sometimes physical safety and
scaffolding that i needed
uh where my parents were just not aware
of some of the things
that were happening within school within
social settings um the hair touching the
just the
there's a number of things that go on
within
um within that experience and i'm a
light-skinned
woman you know dark-skinned boys had
would have had a much harder time
in my community and did
and from that experience that you just
shared with us thank you for sharing by
the way
um what did you kind of take away
from the actions of your parents and
what do you wish that other parents
who um who adopt children of color would
know
before they make that commitment um
well it's just it's really like deeply
self-reflective and it's like deep
identity work
right this work that most adopted
persons especially those that are
adopted trans-racially that identity
work that has to be done
is usually done like on our own without
guides
so adoptive parents of any children
specifically
white adoptive parents adopting black
and brown kids have to do their deep
identity work they have to look at their
personal operating systems
and how they move in the world with
privilege and really think about how
that
impacts their children and the fact that
they
can't their children can't move around
the world the same way that they can
yes there are some privileges that come
with being surrounded and scaffolded out
in the world with a white family that's
present with you but the minute that
white family goes away and you are out
in the world as a black or brown person
this world sees you differently the
world reacts to you differently
and a lot of times just white adoptive
parents are just are not
in that headspace having not had to do
that
for the better part of their lives so i
i wish my parents had
had a better understanding of of
adoption and what that meant of leaving
a family of origin
and also had been encouraged by the
professionals around them to really
think about their racial identity how
their family makeup changes and the
change and how i would need different
things than
my siblings down to like hair care
products quite frankly so there's
it's deep it's vast and we've only
really scratched the surface in helping
families really understand what it means
to be blended in this way
and broadening out those lessons to our
viewers who
just want to know how to talk to kids
about race in general
um what are some takeaways that that you
can offer to them
i mean you have to be real and honest
you know and and it's okay to not have
every answer to every question um
there's one thing about really opening
up
a regular and normal and ongoing
proactive conversation about anything
that's complicated particularly around
race
uh and culture differences so if this is
just part of your operating system if
you talk about these tough things
on the regular and they're not like oh
let's sit down and talk about this right
now today i mean those
those conversations need to happen
around the talk around what happens when
you
are engaged with police and law
enforcement those conversations have to
happen
but every day conversations about
complexity about race
about how you feel about things how some
things make you mad angry sad
how you will protect uh your child these
are the things that have to become part
of our
our systems of operation uh and every
parent really wants to do that
they may have the will to do that but
not the skill so i so it's it's also
about practice right you need 10 000
hours of practice to become
expert at something and if parents enter
into transracial adoption with
a very few hours of practice about
negotiation and negotiating and facing
differences of race
and culture in class they've gotta like
up their game
and get some more hours in and make sure
that they're becoming expert on behalf
of the children entrusted to them
we've talked a bit about the national
conversations surrounding blended
families i'm wondering
how joe biden and kamala hair
specifically have opened up that
conversation
you know looking at kamala i as a as a
black biracial woman looking at her take
the stage as a vp nominee and watching
her career before that
there's something that's just so magical
and amazing and moving and validating
and
inspiring about seeing that i
underestimated
seeing those family structures present
you know joe biden
as it was um had lost his first wife and
then jill comes in as
as mom to the children that have from
the first marriage and then
they create their own family and
children attached to that family so it's
a big blended family and then kamala and
doug right she became homila
i underestimated seeing those family
structures
as a way of seeing myself because the
one thing i i often looked for
um the black and brown kids because i
thought everybody had a black or brown
kid in their family until i went to
school and
there were many black and brown kids uh
so i was also then always looking for my
family structure
there wasn't a there wasn't a family
that looked like my family right that
um different strokes looked like my
family right like
arnold and willis and and quite frankly
i just i grew up on a farm in rhode
island i was like how come i couldn't
be adopted by mr drummond and park
avenue right those are the
the fantasy families that i recognize
that look like mine
uh today when i see families like the
bidens and the
uh harris mha families i feel like
it's just a signal to what families are
today
and we've got to catch up in our schools
in our
medical practices anywhere that that
family is met right um we have to have
this expanded view of family and quite
frankly also in advertising and
marketing as a former marketer
um really we have to we have to really
speak to these families authentically
not just because it's cute
or because it's something that um you
know we think is is
is is clever it's about what these
families are today and if you meet those
families
you and you you don't like close out
other families it raises everything
everybody's better when we look more
broadly
right right and looking more
specifically into kamala harris and joe
biden like you were saying
how does that impact them as people
going through
these experiences of adoption what do
you think that kind of shapes them
towards as leaders
well i feel like when you have had to
negotiate
really complicated relationships and and
those that we speak of when it comes to
the bidens and to
with with even kamala and her husband
doug you know
divorce remarriage differences of race
uh different cultures and even amy's
family right like when you've had to
negotiate some complicated
dynamics and of which family
relationships are our most
you know our most complicated generally
when you've had to navigate that and you
do that well which it seems as though
the bidens and the
and the uh you know the the kamal and
doug have
um there is something to that there is
something to
being able to navigate those things with
grace
and um with with authenticity that
that does prepare you to navigate other
things that are complicated
right so i think there's definitely
nothing wrong with traditional families
to be clear but when there are
complicated circumstances within a
family structure
uh and that you navigate and that you
are are open about talking about i think
there's something really valuable on
that
as as leaders and we touched on this
earlier but
um you mentioned amy coney barrett again
and i just want to dig into this idea
that some folks think that she could be
an ally um
if put into the supreme court and i'm
wondering what your thoughts are on that
and kind of her proximity to people of
color
well you know again just very on the on
the surface level we don't know much
about amy right
um we know that she has black children
she knows that she adopted from haiti we
know that she has other children born to
her we know
there's a there's a deep um you know
sort of centering on religion
but we don't know does she have black
and brown friends have they
in incorporated the haitian culture of
her children into their home
do they have black art on the walls do
they have um
you know a really diverse group of
friends coming into their home on the
regular do her black children see her
loving black people
right like that's the first place where
she can prove herself as an ally is to
her children
right um and model what it looks like to
be in
in right relationship to something
that's different yes she probably loves
her children but does she love
blackness and black excellence does she
even know what that means right so i
think
you know again you cannot assume that
ally ship
in any way shape or form because of the
transaction of adopting
where that allyship it comes to light
and where that
is real is when you see her with
like fighting for justice fighting for
black people fighting for immigration
fighting for um pro-choice because when
you think about it
um that is also allyship is is is
attached to that as well on some level
right
it's deep and and i feel like we don't
know her well enough
to know some of her inner workings we
know her we know her well enough
from a policy and law standpoint but we
don't know her inner workings on really
what allyship looks like
i i it remains to be seen but i have my
guesses
of how that will go and i think it will
will likely be in direct opposition to
um what you know we'd all like to see in
terms of
uh sort of racial uh like really
reckoning and facing differences of race
not just sort of glossing it over
and we've seen a lot of white
influencers sort of adopting children of
color and tokenizing them
and monetizing content about their
children's experiences
so i'm wondering if you can talk about
some of the problematic behaviors that
we've seen and whether
white families should should be
transracially adopting children
well first and foremost children should
never be commoditized commodified or
uh exploited i mean we we work when we
we work on uh keeping children safe and
not exploiting them in
certain ways and then you have vloggers
and and
and influencers that are that are that
are clocking their every move
uh around adopting and and then really
um when things aren't going well uh
leaving so many people uh angry and
disturbed
about you know we're talking about the
stauffers the the the family that
adopted a chinese boy and then ended up
basically rehoming him or having him
re-adopted uh
you know these things are just not
protected they're not you're not
protecting children
when you do those things so i think
there's like and that's universal i i
have a problem with any minor children
being
exposed in such a way especially if
they're adopted especially if they're
a different race than their families i
think that that scaffolding gets even
more
urgent around that um so to be clear
i am not opposed to transracial adoption
uh
i am living proof that you know we make
it through
these experiences i have an amazing
family um were they tuned in to certain
things no
are they more now yes we make sure of
that
uh with that though we need a
much better sort of mandated um
conversation training and uh
you know not even just encouragement
this is like this is these are mandates
that
white adaptive parents need to be sort
of clued in trained
um and have ongoing support uh to help
them
and and truth be told another piece of
this which we cannot
not talk about is you know the
disproportionality of black and brown
kids in the foster care system and the
fact that
many children are removed um when they
shouldn't be removed and more so from
black and brown families than white
families so that's another conversation
but we the systematic race of an
institutional racism that exists
in in our world is alive and well in
foster care and adoption today
uh just and there's no way around that
which means we have to talk about
these differences of race and we have to
talk about you know helping families
stay together
and when there is no other way but to
have an adoption take place then that is
okay
but to do so at the highest level of
engagement with as much information
and as much real scrutiny quite frankly
as possible so that these children have
what we are promising which is physical
emotional and psychological safety of a
family
to to support and love them
april what have we not talked about um i
know we're running out of time here but
what else do we need to know on this
topic
before we let you go well when we're
doing this work around trans-racial
adoption
well and when we're doing it at the
highest level of engagement
it is a lesson in how to navigate and
face
differences of race for the world right
um that is not why
a lot of folks go into this trans-racial
adoption uh journey they want to have a
kid they want to raise a kid i get that
but when and i know plenty of families
that are doing an amazing job
at creating the right circumstances for
their kid to be seen
heard protected uh in environments i
mean they're literally just
changing their whole way of operating in
order to protect
this child and create a life um that
that can be
a beautiful uh one lived when that
happens at its highest level
that is a signal to how we all should be
thinking about
how to steer into complexity how to be
in a really really transformational
place around differences of race
um that is not their job that is not
those families job to be that
for us in the world but when it happens
it is like this is what everybody should
be doing in terms of really
understanding their racial identity
being anti-racist and anti-biased
and when families do it right it's it's
a lesson for all of us
april thank you so much for joining us
and taking the time to talk us through
your journey uh for those who are
watching you can find april's podcast
born in june raised in april and uh
thank you so much for watching please
continue to follow bloomberg quick take
on all social platforms wherever you get
your news
thank you so much